because the black coat store is a
sinister tale of demonic possession and
murder well starting off slow the movie
intensifies throughout it's quite normal
to begin with but as it goes on it
becomes more depraved and twisted you
the way that the film manipulates time
and recast characters it can be quite
hard to follow so I just thought I'd put
together a little plot synopsis which
hopefully explains the film and also
gives my theory towards exactly what I
think it's about the film follows Rosen
cap students at a prestigious boarding
school who are prepared to be picked up
by their parents cat has a premonition
which she sees a parent's car horribly
smashed up and begins to worry that they
might never arrive Rose also worries
about something she thinks she may be
pregnant and delays her parents arrival
in order to tell her boyfriend after
never being picked up on the final day
of school both students must remain in
the boarding dormitory until their
parents arrive Rose sneaks out one night
to inform a boyfriend that she may be
pregnant and you this will be getting a
termination if it is the case upon
return the school she travels down in
the basement where she sees cat
performing a ritualistic prayer beside
an open furnace meanwhile a girl named
Joan arrives in upstate New York and
whilst waiting for the bus is greeted by
bill someone who offers her a ride much
the anger of his wife so that kind of
introduces the characters into it and
throughout the film that focuses on
their
from normality to the very twisted John
awakens in a hotel room she takes a
shower and a bullet scar can be seen on
her shoulder in a flashback the police
officer shoots a rifle at her bill
knocks and tells Joan the reason he
picked her up is because she reminds him
of someone he invites her to have dinner
with him at the restaurant next door
where he shows Joan a picture of his
daughter Rose Joan excuses herself and
goes to the bathroom where she giggles
and has a memory of killing a woman and
stealing her identification card John
sees bill talking to a cop and whilst
they're distracted she steals a knife
from a bust ray bill and informs John
that they have to hit the road to beat
an impending storm and Joan goes to the
car well Linda his wife is waving Linda
tells John that bill sees rose and every
young girl but that she doesn't see Rose
and Jona all back at the school cat
tells rose that her parents are not
coming at dinner cat begins vomiting and
when a chaperone tries to comfort her
she lashes out when mr. Gordon the head
teacher arrives at the house he's
accompanied by a police officer the same
officer that we saw in John's flashback
earlier on upon entering the house mr.
Gordon grasps his face in horror in a
flashback cat has seen answering a
payphone and hears the gravelly voice on
the other end which she calls dad tells
her that a parent's oncoming and to kill
everyone late a cat has seen stabbing
the two chaperones to death well it's
one of the victims crawls along the
floor mortally wounded cat casually
walks upstairs returns with two
pillowcases then finishes the job Rose
goes to the bathroom and gets a period
sighing in relief she hears someone into
the bathroom but then leave when she
goes to the dormitory stairwell she sees
two bloody heads wrapped in pillowcases
and hurries back to the hall cat appears
and stabs Rose to death before
decapitating her the police officer
finds cat in the boiler room kneeling in
front of the lip boiler and surrounded
by the heads of the three victims cat
stands up and weirdly goes
and when she failed to drop the night
she gets shot Joan is in the car with
Bill and Linda Linda reveals to Joan
that Rose was brutally murdered nine
years earlier and decapitated Joan say
she's going to be sick and bill calls
over Joan then leans forward slashes
Bill's throat and stabs Linda to death
she cuts off their heads and puts them
in a suitcase which she carries at the
boarding school which is now boarded up
father bream visits cat in the psychic
ward and performs an exorcism cat seems
to see a shadow demonic figure she asks
it to stay with her but it disappears
Joan who is now revealed to be an older
cat and as the boiler room with a
suitcase only to find the room dark and
cold she exits school and looks back as
she begins to sob hit with the
realization of what she's done there's a
lot to take in here and there's
certainly no clear answer whilst the
film centers around demonic possession I
personally think it might be a metaphor
for how the Catholic Church operates
towards young girls Rose when worried
that she's pregnant states she might
have an abortion and the two chaperones
that are killed are rumored to be devil
worshippers obviously the Catholic
Church doesn't agree with any of those
things so I think the demon might be a
manifestation of all the bad will that
Catholics have towards doing these sort
of things
there's also similarities to the
Slenderman murders that recently
happened in the fact that there's a girl
who's very clearly manipulated by a
malevolent force so I'm kind of sure
that the producers and writers took
inspiration from that I've also seen
theories that the film is meant to be a
sequel of Donnie Darko they both contain
demonic bunny geared villains that will
the protagonist to do things and I can
sort of see this both the characters
seem to go along with devilish plots
without really resisting them and there
are certainly some similarities there I
don't know for sure though and the film
is very hard to analyze especially after
just one view it I'd love to hear your
theories on it I'm sure you've probably
got better one
to mean so comment below and let me know
or do you agree with what I said who
knows if you want to see more film game
TV reviews by me then make sure you head
over a definition car at UK like and
subscribe my channel Cheers